c'est le cauchemar pour tout dirigeant
soit des incendies ou de la police qui
se passent
cauchemar pour tout pompier notre
mission c'est d'abord et avant tout le
sauver des vies les pompiers pompiers
qui sont arrivés le matin le lundi on
fait toute la possibles pour sauver les
gens qui pouvaient sauver qui était dans
les fenêtres etc mais malheureusement
même à l'arrivée des premiers pompiers
pompiers
l'intensité de l'incendie faisant en
sorte qu'on pouvait pas pénétrer loin
dans le bâtiment vous en avez sauvé neuf
il y a 9 qui ont été transportés
plusieurs ont été sauvés par des
échelles une personne qui a sauté je
crois qu'il y a deux personnes qui sont
sortis deux même du sous-sol mais il y
avait 9 transports en tout directeur les
mêmes dites moi quelque chose à vue
d'oeil on voit bien que le propriétaire
ne respecte pas toutes les mesures
prévention incendie
mais on connaît rien factuellement on
est en train de faire l'enquête à
première vue c'est impossible de rien
boire de l'extérieur du bâtiment nous le
camp des pompiers et pompiers sont
arrivés et ont fait leur possible faire
des sauvetages mais on a toujours pas
connaissance à 100% de comment
l'intérieur était configuré les
prochains jours qui suivent pour les
pompiers quel est l'objectif de
d'essayer d'aller exciciper les dépôts
nous c'est notre groupe de sauvetage
technique si sur les lieux et qui
soutient les enquêteurs d'aspvm du SPVM
pour essayer d'expliquer les personnes
de façon sécuritaire le dernier chose
qu'on veut c'est que quelqu'un se blesse
ou soit tuer par un effondrement ou vous
savez il y a plus de plancher dans
plusieurs endroits c'est très dangereux
donc notre groupe de sauvetage technique
s'occupe d'assurer la sécurité il
enquête et Chat Potté par les enquêteurs
de Spurs une pièce qui n'a pas de
fenêtre c'est pas légal pour un pompier
je vais pas rentrer dans l'aspect
réglementaire parce qu'on est vraiment
encore à l'étape de sortir toutes les
victimes possibles plus rapidement
possible et de préserver tout ce qu'on
peut du bâtiment très bien mais c'est
que c'est les parents des victimes qui
se posent des questions aussi faites de
la guerre là c'est quoi votre rôle au
cours des prochains jours mais c'est un
rôle méticuleux avec les enquêteurs
d'aller sur la scène de crime allez
vérifier pas à pas qu'est-ce qu'on peut
recueillir comme information il y a il y
avait cette personne absente une on l'a
sorti il en reste 6 est-ce qu'elle a
d'autres à l'intérieur faute extrêmement
vigilant sur ce qu'on va dire ce qu'on
va faire parce qu'on sait pas s'il y a
d'autres personnes on pense qu'on est à
6 est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres on sait
pas je vous repose la question je sais
que l'enquête est en cours puis vous
êtes prudent vous deux et on comprend
mais pour les familles des victimes
justement ils se disent il y a quelque
chose qui ne tourne pas rond qu'on
laisse des bâtiments comme ça mal
inspectés des issues mal cernés pas
déçus dans certains cas l'appel au 91
est clair quand même oui et puis ils
vont avoir des onses
malheureusement puis franchement tout à
l'heure c'est avec un des membres de la
famille chaque minute c'est trop long et
ça risque de prendre plusieurs jours
donc je veux m'assurer que les premiers
mois ils soient bien accompagné qu'ils
aient l'aide nécessaire de passer à
travers ce drame mais il va avoir des
réponses et sûr mais là à ce moment-là
on peut pas le donner et des accusations
possiblement contre le propriétaire on
verra qu'est-ce qui va se passer par la
suite on verra trop tôt pour se
prononcer combien de temps on estime ce
qui reste à faire pour les débris pour
le nous on a monté notre un plan
d'opération pour deux semaines donc nous
nos collègues des pompiers puis Richard
il avait mangé tout à l'heure c'était
héros les premiers propices sont allés
sur les lieux et nos policiers mettant
les enquêteurs qui travaillent sur le
lieu j'en suis extrêmement fier parce
que
vous savez ce qu'on va découvrir
ce sera un désastre et c'est des corps
qui ont été brûlés ce sera un désastre
donc humainement parlant j'ai passé pour
les familles vraiment mais sympathie
pour toutes les familles des proches
ceux qui sont dans l'inquiétude
présentement mais aussi nos confrères
constructeurs sont en train de
travailler sur la scène c'est pas c'est
pas évident de tout ce qu'ils vont voir
ce qu'ils sont en train de voir
présentement chef les mains il y a eu un
décès aussi dans un autre incendie
on ne le rappelle jamais assez d'être
prudent évidemment mais d'avoir des
détecteurs de fumée qui fonctionnent on
fait notre possible chaque changement
d'heure on fait des Blitz aussitôt
incendie qui implique qu'un incendie
majeur un dessin un blessé à blessé on
fait des Blitz dans le quartier pour
sensibiliser les gens pendant qu'ils
sont réceptifs aux messages on le répète
souvent mais vous avez raison on peut
pas le répéter assez les avertisseurs de
fumée sauf des vies ça vous donne le
temps de sortir avant qu'un incendie
devient tellement violent qu'on est plus
capable de sortir
on va suivre ça merci Monsieur merci
bonne chance au revoir